empecemos por decir que este es el
primer gran pronunciamiento de la corte
sobre la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo desde que derogó el histórico
fallo de Rover versus White que daba
acceso precisamente al aborto a nivel
Federal en qué queda entonces la batalla
legal del aborto en Estados Unidos y
especialmente sobre la mifepristona
Buenas noches Sí mira creo que es
importante aclarar que son dos casos
completamente diferentes el caso de era
un caso constitucional era un caso sobre
sí existía o no derecho constitucional y
si era algo que el derecho
constitucional al aborto hiciera algo
que debía depender del Gobierno Federal
o de los gobiernos estatales en el caso
de la mipe prestona es un caso que están
hablando de una del poder regulatorio de
algo administrativo que tiene la etda
esto definitivamente son grandes
noticias para el acceso al aborto sin
ninguna duda ese es un caso que fue
fabricado por el movimiento anti
derechos que ellos formaron una compañía
Precisamente en esta jurisdicción de
este juez que fue un juez dominado por
el expresidente Trump específicamente el
único juez Federal que podía tener
jurisdicción sobre casos federales en
este distrito y que llega al quinto
circuito que puede pues uno de los
circuitos más
observadores que existen con respecto a
muchísimos temas entonces la corte lo
que está haciendo Es realmente por lo
menos temporalmente mientras los
procesos de apelaciones siguen
permitiendo que el uso de la microsona
vuelva a lo que había originalmente
decidido la fda hace más de 20 años
entonces es como si Ninguno de los casos
anteriores hubiera existido usted
mencionó que los grupos antiderechos
estuvieron detrás de este de esta
presentación del caso ante los jueces al
respecto Entonces cuál es la fuerza que
están tomando los grupos religiosos y
ultraconservadores para llevar este tipo
de temas ante los tribunales está en
juego la capacidad de las entidades
científicas a la hora de decidir sobre
temas de salud
pero yo creo que la corte acaba de
mandar un mensaje claro y es que por lo
menos no se va a tomar una decisión como
estas de una forma ligera si bien
sorprende que los jueces alito y los
jueces tomas tuvieran como una un voto
disidente sobre esta decisión igual te
muestra que no es un caso de aborto
común y corriente sino es un caso que
tiene implicaciones que van muchísimo
más grandes porque lo que está en juego
es si las decisiones con respecto a los
medicamentos las puede tomar un juez o
las debe tomar una entidad regulatoria
científica basada en un panel de
expertos científicos como es la fda
entonces creo que te da un poquito de
indicaciones de Por qué este caso es
diferente a los otros y también Creo que
demuestra Qué tan lejos están dispuestos
a llegar los grupos anti derechos que no
les importan las consecuencias que pueda
tener para otros medicamentos para este
caso tenía implicaciones para cualquier
medicamento que pueda ser aprobado por
la fda